professeur dubernard bonsoir vous êtes
chef du service de transplantation de
l'hôpital edouard herriot
alors est ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer peut-être par un schéma
comment ça s'est passé comment vous avez
travaillé tous ensemble
écoutez on a simplement à partir du
greffon et du membre qui avaient été
prélevés chez un donneur anonyme
quelque part en france dont la famille
avait été informée de l'intervention
totalement informés et sur un corps qui
avait été parfaitement restaurée elle
était l'aide d'une prothèse
nous avons ramené le bras à l'hôpital
edouard herriot et nous l'avons préparé
en sectionnant à un niveau adapté à la
longueur du moignon qui persistait chez
clint ensuite nous avons préparé la et
individualisé repéré chacun des éléments
les deux principales artères cinq ou six
des principales veine les trois
principaux nerfs qui sont là les deux os
et simultanément une autre équipe
nous étions huit chirurgiens du quatre
pays différents une autre équipe
préparée l'extrémité du royaume il avait
recoupé recherché à ce niveau les
artères les veines les nerfs et les
individualiser et les repérer et ensuite
le tout le travail a consisté à savoir
fixer les eaux puis à suturer les
artères pour que là pour que le sang
irrigue à nouveau la main les veines les
nerfs et nous avons les muscles les 21
ans domus blanc fait de notre mieux pour
que toutes les structures du monde soir
soit reconstituée mais vous n'avez pas
situés tous les nerfs on a reconstitué
la plus grande partie des nerfs et nous
avons suture f
le plus souvent à chaque fois que cela
était possible fascicule par fascicule
cire que l'on pense à pelé ne soient pas
contrôlés de mettre bout à bout les
nerfs mais les fascicules nerveux à
l'intérieur de chaque nerfs c'est ça qui
a pris le plus grand temps en réalité
c'est une opération qui marque une étape
dans l'histoire des transmutations qui a
été réalisé pour donner le plus grand
champ sedan 2
chances de succès aux malades et c'est
la raison pour laquelle leurs associés à
la fois des chirurgiens orthopédistes
des micros chirurgiens et des
chirurgiens de transplantation de façon
à part lorsque concrètement je vous
montrais c est ce qu est ce qui pourra
faire avec sa main il pourra pincer ou
est-ce qu'il retrouvera complètement
l'utilité de sa main pour le moment
c'est un succès technique mais on peut
pas préjuger du résultat fonctionnel le
résultat fonctionnel on le jugera dans
12 à 18 mois
quand les maires les films nerveuse
auront repoussé et progresser jusqu'à
l'extrémité des doigts et lorsqu'il aura
retrouvé une sensibilité et une
motricité normale comme après une
section où une réimplantation ou
réimplante une partie d'individus sur
lui-même
à ce moment là on pourra dire que
l'opération est un succès mais il reste
encore pendant les jours à venir
la question du rejet nous avons mis au
point un protocole des minots
suppression spécial associant les
molécules les plus puissantes qui existe
est aussi des crèmes immunosuppressives
qui devrait nous permettre de traiter la
question qui nous inquiète le plus
celle du rejet de la peau mais c'est une
aventure extraordinaire en étant et et
tous les jours il faut s'attendre à voir
des nouveaux problèmes à résoudre mais
c'est c'est le prix de prix à payer pour
faire progresser cette opération est
pour qu elle offre des chances à des
milliers de personnes victimes
d'accidents domestiques d'accidents du
travail
victime de manipulation de mines les
mine anti personnelle voire de
malformations congénitales de retrouver
l'espoir de retrouver une fonctionnalité
et une image corporelle normal merci
beaucoup professeurs